[Musique]
si vous voulez connaître les secrets de
l'univers penser en termes de fréquence
et de vibrations disait nicolas tesla
j'ai compris le sens de cette phrase i à
peu près 20 ans quand en 1989 j'ai
découvert l'influencent de la musique
sur les végétaux et sur les animaux
j'ai eu la chance pour cela de grandir
dans une exploitation agricole qui m'a
permis de faire mes petites expériences
et très tôt je commence dès l'âge de 16
ans à et faire des expériences sur les
animaux en diffusant de la musique de
variété j'obtiens peu de résultats
satisfaisants plus tard j'entreprends
d'autres résultats qui nous donneront
finalement beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
satisfaction puisque j'utilise la
musique de beethoven et de mozart à
raison de deux heures par jour sur des
groupes de 12 et très vite j'obtiens des
résultats étonnants les animaux sont
plus jeunes plus joueur et recherchent
beaucoup plus facilement le contact de
l'homme quant aux animaux qui produisent
du lait il est de meilleure qualité il
est plus ah bon le lait plus abondant
pour les végétaux ils sont plus denses
plus plus éclatant plus florissant
poussé par cette petite réussite je
continue à faire des recherches d'emploi
ensuite des musiques de méditation et
l'ambiance est là encore je tombe
vraiment vers des résultats étonnants
les animaux recherche de façons qui
systématique le contact de l'homme
ils sont vraiment vraiment beaucoup plus
doux dans leur comportement en général
ils sont ils sont un poil beaucoup plus
brillant enfin il ya vraiment quelque
chose qui change dans les musiques de
méditation et d'ambiance simplement et à
un moment donné je me je me pose des
questions que je dis pourquoi cette
musique fonctionne parce que je
m'aperçois avec certaines musiques ils
sont agressifs agités voire
avoir des comportements presque
dangereux avec l'homme et là je
m'interroge vraiment beaucoup pourquoi
cette musique pourquoi d'autres élèves
par le plus grand des hasards en 1999
j'écoute une fois de plus un morceau de
john lennon et je découvre que le la est
accordée à 432 là je commence et il nous
musique d'aujourd'hui sont accordés à
440 et je cherche je cherche je sais de
trouver des correspondances et je
m'aperçois qu'au fil des siècles on a
modifié beaucoup les fréquences musicale
et en recherchant en recherchant
toujours je m'aperçois que finalement en
je ne trouve rien qui me donne du
résultat en tous les cas sur le plan
connaissance entre le lien est l'homme
en fréquence 440 par contre je trouve
beaucoup en 432 j'en trouve énormément
je vous parlais de la première que j'ai
trouvée quand on accorde la musique à
432 la sole est à 384 hertz quand on
sait que la fréquence de l'oxygène et
384 hertz et qu'on a vécu t on aère le
sol pour lui donner de l'oxygène pur
qu'il respire pour que ça pousse mieux
et qui s'appelle aussi le sol
c'est quand même pas banal la deuxième
fait que quand on accorde aussi à 1 432
le dos lui est à 2 156 heures ce qui
correspond à la fréquence de résonance
de l'acsi mutation chlorophyllienne donc
là aussi intéressant le lien si je
continue dans un autre domaine on
s'aperçoit que la pyramide de khéops et
de 432 unités terrestres au niveau de la
base qui est l insee de mesure à
l'époque
si on continue on s'aperçoit que par
exemple pyramides de teotihuacan et l 2
864 ups qui n'a été aussi l'unité de
mesure à l'époque qui est donc la moitié
de 432 si on s'arrête au calendrier des
mayas rond n'a dans le cycle de quantum
on a un cycle de sept mille deux cents
jours et si on extrait 72 de 7200 jours
on a aussi on obtient un sixième de 432
pardon dans le calendrier
veda on a quatre cent trente deux mille
ans dans la bible on retrouve plusieurs
fois le suivre 144 qui est aussi un art
monique durée quand on accorde à 432
dans le
la pulsation minutes d'un être humain
quand il est également au repos on
ferait aussi de 60 de spéciation munich
donc il ya beaucoup de correspondances
qui sont mis en évidence
et si on parle de l'eau dont nous sommes
constitués nous sommes constitués dos à
plus de 70 % ce qui n'est pas banal on
sait aujourd'hui les antilles de la
science nous aide beaucoup là dessus que
l'eau cap de l'information et donc les
premiers à mettre en évidence était le
docteur benveniste et le docteur et
motos qui ont beaucoup sont deux
chercheurs scientifiques renommés qui
ont beaucoup travaillé sur l'eau ont
découvert que la fréquence 432 est
qualifié pour eux de naturel
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont calculé que les
fréquence de résonance des atomes et des
molécules dans la nature et vérifier que
l'oscillation à 432 était une situation
qui correspondait à la résonance de
l'eau donc il est vraiment intéressant
de découvrir ces recherches skis et ski
est aussi passionnant c'est que quand on
écoute cette musique à 432 elle est
légèrement plus douces l1 sont plus
relax ans il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différences entre les deux mais elles
sont plus douce et plus relaxant quand
on écoute à 440 ça crispe légèrement le
corps est progressivement d'ailleurs
c'est sans doute pour ça aussi on dit
que certains biologistes avaient dit
qu'il y avait un désaccord entre le
maquereau cause c'est le micro gosse
quand on accorde à 440
alors moi je me suis équipé d'appareils
pour photographier l'énergie des gens
sains en fonction des musiques qu'on
écoute alors là c'est c'est donc c'est
magique et sur le sur la partie sombre
du côté droite
là elle écoute une musique 440 et sur la
gauche sur la droite par dont l écoute
une musique que je crois que c'était le
canon de pachelbel si je me souviens
bien oui c'est ça il a envoyé son aura
n'est pas du tout le même
ç'a vraiment eu un impact la musique est
vraiment un impact sur nous elle a aussi
beaucoup un impact sur les végétaux pas
ce que je fais aussi pousser des
végétaux de toutes sortes et voilà ce
que ça peut donner sur une carotte
ça c'est une carotte qui a poussé avec
de la musique
normal et ça c'est une carotte qui a
poussé avec de la musique à normal on
pourrait dire voilà ça fait des carottes
difformes dont j'ai pris les extrêmes
sont des extrêmes
bon elle et elle paraît peut-être un peu
esseulé tout ça ne m'aide beaucoup plus
grosse et ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'autre car en plus un peu malade alors
parfois ça donne des carottes très
petites qui sont pas très joli mais
d'une façon générale s'est diffusée à
raison de deux heures par jour et voilà
ce qu'on obtient on obtient aussi sur
les sur les plantes parce qu'on peut
photographier l'énergie des plantes
qu'elles dégagent savoir que les plantes
ça dégage une énergie et c'est quelque
chose de vivant d'ailleurs ce qu ont la
main verte il doit le savoir
voilà ce que ça dégage sur une plante en
fréquence à 440 sur la droite et en 432
sur la gauche
donc cette énergie en général
aujourd'hui on la mesure avec différents
appareils là on la photographie et
comment dirais-je si vous arrêter un
instant sur le sur la musique 432 vous
verrez que vous sentirez beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs toutes les musiques qui ont
été faites en 432 en général fait par
des chanteurs qui ont été très
populaires et apporte vraiment un
bien-être constant et régulier en
général ça des morceaux qu'on a beaucoup
écouté dans le jeu paraître ça juste
parce que c'est quelque chose que je
trouve important donc ça c'est une
expérience que j'ai c'est un appareil
qui photographient des énergies faut
savoir que quand vous vous êtes en
colère que vous n'êtes pas bien vous
êtes triste on a eu ce qu'on appelle une
énergie folle lumineuse ou plutôt
photonique on émane des photons en
permanence au niveau du visage
particulièrement au niveau du visage et
en permanence et si vous êtes triste que
vous êtes pour bien les alpes à la
flèche
vous allez avoir plutôt une couleur
rouge sombre et donc vous êtes du doigt
terme en assez bas et par contre si vous
êtes bien si vous êtes en forme gay tout
s'est bien passé dans votre journée vous
allez plutôt avoir une couleur bleue et
donc ça c'est ma fille qui est sur le
premier cliché qu'il ne se prend la tête
avec son frère
et dans le premier cliché sur la gauche
donc elle et elle commence à marconnelle
et pour bien dans celui du centre elle
pleurait elle avait envie de le taper
avec ses dons vous voyez une zone rouge
autour de son visage qui apparaît et
quand elle va bien on a parlé un petit
peu
voyez qu'à une zone bleue qui apparaît
au niveau de son visage aussi quand tout
va bien quand la personne est vraiment
plus détendu et que la finale par lâcher
donc nos attitudes dégage une énergie
dégage une couleur on peut le mesurer
aujourd'hui à la fois par des tas de
commandes de test donc c'est assez
intéressant de gaulle pour les végétaux
c'est aussi la même chose sachez qu'un
végétal c'est quelque chose de vivant et
c'est le premier à découvrir sa set et
pop en 1975 il avait découvrir que le
végétal si vous l'agresser il va
automatiquement en grand chez un système
de rayonnement lumineux comme système
d'autodéfense donc là c'est un j'ai pris
un cliché avant de l'agression du
végétal sur la gauche et vous avez
ensuite un cliché sur la droite où il ya
une tout brille ans au dessus du végétal
voyez sur la gauche c'est pas tellement
brillance et blanc plutôt un sévère
pardon et sur la droite c'est brillant
c'est vraiment l'énergie lumineuse
j'ai coupé 1 j'ai coupé devant avec eux
avec un tempérament agressif et voilà ce
que ça dégage et comme comme rayonnement
lumineux donc nos comportements sur les
végétaux sur les animaux aussi est sûre
les gens bien évidemment ont une
influence et on peut aujourd'hui le
mesurer et le démontrer en tout cas
alors j'ai fait pas mal de 2
2 comment dirais-je d'expérience j'ai
découvert donc on pouvait tuer qu'on
pouvait faire végéter qu'on pouvait
rendre florissante qu'on pouvait
vraiment rendent éclatant en fonction
des types de musique qu'on ne compte
diffuser sur les animaux et sur les
végétaux
j'ai pas fait beaucoup d'essais sur les
humains mais j'ai fait beaucoup d'essais
sur les animaux et là je peux vous dire
que c'est assez sidérant c'est assez
incroyable ce que ça peut faire sur un
humain parce que j'ai fait récemment sur
un humain il n'y a pas très longtemps
après l'avoir fait sur un végétaux mais
j'en ai pas fait beaucoup mais le si peu
qu'on fait je peux vous dire que c'est
assez impressionnant donc et fêtes foyer
vigilants à la musique que vous écoutez
ce que je peux dire c'est que vous savez
qu on a sept centres énergétiques qui
sont reliés à cette note de remy fa sol
la si
et c'est cette note correspondent à un
organe chaque organe a aussi et sa
propre fréquence et une fréquence donnée
mais ce qu'on s'est un peu moins c'est
que chaque acides aminés a aussi sa
propre fréquence et va se fixer sur le
ribosome en permanence toujours à la
même fréquence d'accrochages alors vous
avez un morceau qui a été étudié par
edith et nos petit clic est un morceau
qui s'appelle le canon de pachelbel
alors ce morceau là je vais vous dire
une chose
écoutez le tous les jours pourquoi parce
que ce morceau là il a la particularité
faut savoir que sur notre chaîne
polypeptides hic on a à peu près 300
acides aminés
on en a besoin de 8 primordialement dont
on ne peut pas se passer si on les a pas
il faut manger équilibré sinon avoir des
problèmes
ces huit là c'est le seul morceau qu'on
a trouvé qui vous nourrit vaut 1 8
acides aminés essentiels en permanence
il est conçu de 2,8 tonalité qui
correspondent aux huit acides aminés à
l'homme et que s'il est conçu aussi de
telle manière que si vous le prenez en
cours il c'est comme si vous le reprenez
depuis le départ il a quatre couplets
avec des notes semblables c'est un
puissant anti stress
si vous n'êtes pas bien ce soir vous
rentrez du travail vous n'êtes pas bien
écoutez la
si par exemple beaucoup le connaissent
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous dans
la salle l'ont entendu l'on écouté il a
aussi la particularité de réguler le
métabolisme
c'est ils activent le circuit
emblématique il stimule la protéine ce
morceau là est génial il faut vraiment
l'écouter
par contre par contre il ya des musiques
qui sont pour moi des vraie saloperie
et en général les plus populaires il ya
un morceau qu'a contrario qui est
construit sur les mêmes principes que le
canon de pachelbel que je vais vous
citer qui vous avez tous probablement
danser dessus quand même si un morceau
qui a été fait par rabat a repris par
madonna enfin plein d'autres ce morceau
là s'appelle en europe
et quand vous l'écoutez il vous stimule
les mêmes hormones que vous stimulez
quand vous rentrez en forte dépression
c'est une vraie saloperie
alors personnellement ayant étudié un
petit peu aussi mozart quand on est il
du mozart on s'aperçoit que les derniers
morceaux de mozart ont la particularité
d'appauvrir énormément certains acides
aminés mais vraiment surtout ses
derniers morceaux et à l'époque il était
mort d'une maladie du sang une leucémie
donc pour moi ça c'est mon avis
personnel je pense que mozart s'est tué
avec sa musique mais c'est mon avis
parce qu'il appauvrit vraiment beaucoup
d'acides aminés mais vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup
et d'ailleurs quand on utilise sur des
plantes on s'aperçoit que les plantes ne
pousse pas beaucoup et ils ont plutôt
tendance à végéter donc soyez vigilents
la musique que vous écoutez d'ailleurs
platon avait dit si vous voulez
contrôler le peuple contrôler sa musique
je ne sais pas d'où ils sortent et ça
mais il avait dit cette phrase alors on
pourrait imaginer un monde baigné en 432
on serait certainement plus joyeux on
sera certainement plus vivant on aurait
certainement certainement plus
d'intuition je suis convaincu qu'on
aurait plus d'un tuyau est globalement
les ailes soyez vigilants donc au
musique que vous écoutez et au corps
fortement que vous avez car un bon
comportement amène un taux vibratoire
beaucoup plus élevé vous êtes dans vous
les mettez beaucoup plus de bonnes ondes
est automatiquement vous faites du bien
autour de vous et puis d'ailleurs on dit
en général de ces personnes il rayonne
et ça c'est à la fois la musique que
vous entendez les conditions dans
laquelle voulu les écouter et c'est
aussi dans les conditions dans laquelle
vous êtes donc le son peut vous faire
vraiment beaucoup de bien vous épanouir
vous rendre joyeux
vous rêvez vous structurez vous
construire mais il se il peut aussi
malheureusement faire des choses
négatives comme je voulais dit tout à
l'heure je vous remercie
michel michel je ne sais pas prévu mais
s'est demandé à emmanuel cuche sait pas
s'il est là ce qui peut nous jouer
quelques notes des canon de pachelbel
parce que je pense que tout le monde ne
connaît pas cette musique on a envie de
prendre des acides aminés c'était pas
prévu mais je pense que ça fera plaisir
emmanuel juste quelques mesures et ce
qu'il m'a dit ça va être très long mais
c'est une bonne idée
et là ça serait lui faire du bien
beaucoup le connaissent
oui les accords jusqu'à ce qu'ils
connaissent pas
[Musique]
oh
ans
voilà bon la suite est chez vous